hey guys in this video we're going to talk about
the goiter okay let's kinda let's kind of go
through it first of all you have a hypothyroid
case that's a low thyroid that could come from
a low amount of iodine in the diet okay now either
you're not consuming in the diet because it's not
in the food because it's a trace mineral and
our soils are so poor or you could be eating
certain foods that are pulling it out okay so
there's even medications and drugs like sulfa
drugs will deplete iodine lithium will deplete
iodine perchlorate that's in the water supply
that's why you need a house filter that will cause
a depletion of iodine and then thiocyanate that's
from cigarette smoking if you smoke that can also
that chemical can pull iodine out of your thyroid
and then also different foods like yuca soy bean
pine nuts strawberries peaches pears bamboo shoots
sweet potato cruciferous vegetables all those have
the capacity to deplete you of iodine so so it
could be a thyroid situation coming from a lack
of iodine or it could come from a liver problem
or you're low in bile because your gall bladder
is removed in which case you can't convert t4
to t3 so that could be the cause or it could be
high levels of estrogen a lot of women that are
pregnant and have a baby during the process the
thyroid goes down that's because the high mountain
of estrogen that can block the thyroid regardless
of that situation what happens when you're low in
iodine you're not making the thyroid hormones and
so therefore the feedback mechanism is going to
go up to the pituitary and tell the pituitary
to make thyroid stimulating hormone and that
hormone from the pituitary makes the thyroid and
large okay that's the purpose of it so that sends
back here because we're not getting the feedback
loop because when your thyroid is producing normal
amounts of thyroid hormone it should act as a
feedback and turn off the pituitary so it can
stop producing but it's not enough it just keeps
sending communication it's not a little bit of
a circuit and the thyroid gets bigger alright
then you have Hashimoto's that's an autoimmune
situation where your Thyer is making antibodies
that are attacking itself in which case it's
going to block the thyroid hormone so you'll
have low thyroid hormone low iodine sending a
signal back up to the thyroid stimulating hormone
or not sending a signal back and causing this the
pituitary to stimulate the thyroid more to make
it get bigger to the same mechanism but in this
case it's the actual iodine deficiency this is
an immune reaction this is usually created by
stress induced autoimmune type problems most
autoimmune is stress-related in this case you
would want to take iodine and you would also want
to take selenium okay selenium is very important
in the conversion process and also the production
of making thyroid hormones it's part of a certain
enzyme that makes thyroid hormones also it's very
important in vitamin A to take vitamin A if you're
deficient in vitamin A either this one or this
one if you're deficient in vitamin A you're not
going to make thyroid hormones that well so you
need vitamin A vitamin A is in animal products
it's not in it's in vegetables as a pre vitamin
A but not the actual retinol which is the active
form which is mainly in color boil egg yolks and
grass-fed dairy products things like that so or
you might not have a gallbladder and you can't
pull in that vitamin A so that's another source
so if you're taking selenium you need about two
hundred micrograms and by the way what's really
high in selenium is wheatgrass juice which is
interesting okay so we got those two mechanisms
and then we have Grave's which is a high amount
of thyroid hormone production so it's a hyper
thyroid problem so that person is too much iodine
okay so you're not going to give more iodine to a
Grave's type situation and the reason why the
thyroid is enlarging with Grave's is because
the immune system is creating another thing
called thyroid stimulating immunoglobulin TSI
and that is the thing that's making this
get bigger not the pituitary but this immune reaction
okay so you never want to give a person
more iodine or C help if they have Grave's because that's going to worsen it you never
want to
give a person with graves like bowel support or gallbladder support because that will
make
more conversion and make more hormone okay so these foods are probably good not the chemicals
but the foods would be good for Grave's because
it will lower iodine okay now I have a I use
a sea kelp from Iceland which is a very pure
organic certified sea kelp because there's not
many oceans left that are cleaned so that one
is very clean it doesn't have any chemicals in
it it's highly pure and you would take that in
the morning of course not if you have Grave's don't
take it before you go to bed because it increases
energy okay so I just wanted to kind of give
you a background of what is behind goiters and
it doesn't necessarily have to always be a hypo
it could be a hyper alright thanks for watching